so there's another guy
who does what i do
he writes books he gives talks etc his
work is extremely well respected and and
i admire his work as well
i happen to hate him
he's never he's never done anything mean
to me and we've always had a very
quality relationship when we see each
other professionally
i have an arbitrary
hatred of him
and as a result of my hatred
i'm extremely competitive with him
i would log on to amazon on a regular
basis no and check my book rankings and
then immediately check his
and keep in mind i checked no one else's
just the two of us
and if he was ahead i was
angry and if i was a head i was smug
and whenever his name came up in polite
conversation i would see
underneath
we were invited to speak together at a
conference where we would be interviewed
together
and i don't mean like literally we would
be on the stage together and the
interviewer thought it would be fun
if we introduced each other
[Music]
and so i went first
uh and i turned to him
and i said um
you make me really insecure
and i said all of your strengths are all
of my weaknesses
and whenever your name comes up i get
really uncomfortable
and he looked at me and he said
funny i think the same thing about you
the reason i was so competitive with him
had nothing to do with him it had
everything to do with me
because his weaknesses revealed to me
because his strengths reveal to me my
weaknesses
it's more difficult to take a hard look
at myself and say here's all the work
you have to do it's much easier and dare
i say more fun
to
to direct all my energies at beating him
that turned out to be an extremely
cathartic experience
and i learned the value of a worthy
rival
and the funny thing is after that
experience i've never checked
mine or his book wrecking since
um i
applaud his work celebrate him want him
to do well because
it turns out working together
we actually are stronger
and i think this is the same folly in
business right i i
like
you know which is we decide who our
competitors are
and then we obsess with beating them
like abc nbc cbs and fox were obsessed
with beating each other and all they did
was look at nielsen radiations every
morning
and then netflix came up and didn't like
who cares they're all
blowing while the water because they
weren't even looking they weren't even
watching
because that's the arbitrariness of if
you i remember back in the early days
when i first started my career i was in
the ad business and i was junior dog's
buddy to the junior dogs body
and um i was on the um competitive
analysis team
and basically what that meant was we
studied the competition and we put
together decks to the executives of look
what the competition is doing and
we sometimes would hire outside
consultants to run you know research for
us if it was too expensive to study
seven of them we'd cut it down to four
which is hilarious if you think about it
so you're making decisions based on four
and ignore anyway you get my point so um
i think the value of the other players
in your industry of the other players in
the game is not to beat them because
there's no such thing as i said before
you know best buy didn't win anything
when circuit city went bankrupt
but it's to recognize and respect them
there are some players
who do some or many things better than
you maybe they have a better leadership
stronger culture better marketing maybe
their products are better designed who
knows what and instead of trying to beat
them which couldn't mean you choose
underhanded things or just drop your
price
you actually say
okay
let's make our product even better they
have revealed our weakness
let's now work on that because the
ultimate the only competitor
in an infinite game is yourself
you know it's interesting you say that
we have some companies in really really
hyper growth markets right now
and oftentimes when i ask our companies
who are in hyper growth markets
tell me about what's going on
they go right to the competitor yep
and i'm like gosh you have this whole
market just create the awareness yeah
how do we work with our teams who are so
used to focusing on the competition to
make sure that you know how to build
awareness so you make sure that that
netflix doesn't show up today how do you
even set up a culture like that well i
think you asked the question which is i
would like a presentation
on the
other players in the game i don't call
them competitors i call them rivals
because competitors are to be beaten
right so stop calling for one
language matters so let's just stop
calling them competitors let's call them
rivals and some of those rivals are
worthy of comparison and and please do
some research on them and tell me the
things that they're doing better than us
objectively
and then let's look at our own systems
and processes and figure out how we can
then improve those things that were
revealed by their strengths and we wish
them the best of luck remember business
is a game
where two companies can both be wildly
successful selling the same product at
the same time